quand on contracte un cancer les
traitements peuvent être longs et
comporter des effets secondaires
désagréables mais dans certains cas une
approche méconnu la chine aux chaudes
peut mener une rémission en un seul
traitement
[Musique]
cet événement jument papeete
j'étais très stressée d'un diagnostic
qui est difficile à faire c'est une
condition qui est très rare 'cependant
perth à plus de l'anxiété
[Musique]
si on réussit à tout enlever les crises
qu'on est bien parti pour faire ses
chances de guérison sont à peu près 90%
[Musique]
le corps est une puissante machine un
outil incroyable pour relever mille
défis mais parfois cette machine
déraille
pour emma elle a commencé à dérailler il
y a 6 ans dans le bonne et mon ventre
c'est comme écran assez puissant pour
m'empêcher des marchés et même manger
dormir aussi stadistes la présence de
kyste est à l'origine de son mal ils
s'accumulent et grossistes
les taux aux prises avec une maladie
l'eau qui s'est développé dans son rang
au fil des années tranquillement et qui
donne des pistes multiples l'analyse
d'une biopsie confirme le diagnostic
c'est un cancer un mésothéliome multi
kystique de voir al à l'hôpital c'est un
cancer qui pourrait avoir donné
l'emporter si rien n'est fait emma va
bénéficier d'une solution méconnu mais ô
combien efficace
la chimio chaude un traitement mille
fois plus puissant que la chimio par
intraveineuse la libération accueillis
chaleureusement
[Musique]
l'opération pour retirer ce genre de
cancer est évasive on parle de chirurgie
paroisse ouverte mais avec emma c'est
différent
mais si on a la chance parce que la
maladie est relativement localisée le
faire par voie la plus basse qu'au pic
stadio sans souris adultes avec des
caméras qui nous permettent d'enlever
toutes les maladies le mésothéliome est
un cancer qui affecte la membrane qui
recouvre les organes ici ils touchent la
surface de l'intestin du mésothéliome
on va simplement brûlé un sanctuaire à
cellules cancéreuses donc on va aller
mieux enlever en salle d'opération
le chirurgien découvre souvent des
surprises et c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
sur la maison que l'on attendait et les
cellules qui vont rester microscopique -
prise en charge par la chimiothérapie
qu'on va faire appel si on faisait pas
la chimio chauffer ses 90 % de chances
qu'on est obligé de la vie au père était
[Musique]
après une chirurgie qui va durer trois
heures trente
on amorce la pose du drain la chine et
eau chaude peut commencer
ça c'est le thermomètre pour mesurer la
température on a d'un côté le liquide
avec la chimie aux chocs qui rend nos
rangs et de l'autre côté de chimio gaza
quand ça perd plus vraiment bien on est
certains ou à peu près que y'aura pas
que de 20 à londres envoie la chimio on
contemple entrée par une extrémité le
médicament baigne la surface de
l'appeler il pénètre dans le tissu à
moins de 2 mm juste assez pour détruire
les cellules cancéreuses en surface
[Musique]
on donne mille fois plus de chignon en
fait que ce qu'on réussira façon les
administrés par voie intraveineuse ont
détruit littéralement délaissé vêtements
plus chauds que la température interne
du corps humain l'agent de
chimiothérapie circule d'un tube à 42
degrés celsius chaque degré qu'on gagne
ou le strat 7° double d'efficacité de la
chine aux tv quand on augmente la
température de la chimio qui est
administrée on augmente la pénétration
de la chimio dans l'est dans les
cellules dans les tissus dans l'estuaire
et on allait augmenter l'efficacité
le traitement dure 30 minutes 30 minutes
d'action microscopique on s'est vraiment
rendu compte qu'à partir de 30 minutes
y'avait pour plus de médicaments qui
rentrait dans les cellules péritonéale
qui en avait un peu plus qui sans arrêt
dans le sens donc on a augmenté la
toxicité donc le 30 minutes apparaissait
la durée optimale pour maximiser
l'efficacité tout en minimisant la
toxicité
quels patients pourraient avoir à la
soliste m
comme hier la procédure aussi efficace
soit elle ne peut être employé pour tous
les cancers
on utilise uniquement pour traiter les
cellule invisible qui n'ont pas pénétré
dans les organes la chimie aux chaudes
et essentiellement dédié au cancer des
surfaces de l'intestin cantine ils sont
limités aux surfaces de l'intestin
par contre d autres cancers qui ont une
tendance à donner des métastases
ailleurs que sur les surfaces de
l'intestin ce sont pas des cancers qu'on
peut guérir ou en fait aidé avec la
chine au chaud
le traitement est unique mais aussi très
agressif déposer le produit directement
sur la plaie est risqué
la chimiothérapie va augmenter le risque
de complications liées à la chirurgie
donc impatients qui subit une
intervention chirurgicale majeure avec
une chimio chaude à 40 % le risque de
développer des complications et c'est
presque un patient sur deux ce sont des
complications assez souvent facile à
traiter
c'est connu la chimio classique rime
souvent avec de longs mois traitement et
de nombreux rendez vous à l'hôpital
la chimie aux chaudes comme grave
davantage est un traitement unique c'est
à dire que dans la majorité des cas
quand le patient est soumis à ce
traitement là il n'y a pas d'autres
signaux qui sont administrés par les
veines dans les mois qui suivent
depuis l'opération
emma va très bien si j'ai pas eu d'
extrême vomissements je n'ai pas perdu
mes cheveux y aller les effets
secondaires était selon moi moins pire
j'ai vraiment eu la chance que mon
diagnostic est permis cette procédure
seulement juste un traitement est
normalement c'est pas se poser revenir
et je suis guéri il y a quelques années
les patients comme emma avait une
espérance de vie limitée
aujourd'hui tout est possible
[Musique]